greetings I'm Jim Levinson director of
the Jackson Institute for Global Affairs
and I'd like to welcome everybody with a
special welcome to president Levin who's
joining us today today's event is part
of a series the Jackson Institute
conversations on leadership and the
format today will be exactly that a
conversation leading that conversation
and here to introduce secretary Paulson
is the man who has been spearheading the
development of the leadership curriculum
here at the Jackson Institute former
general and current senior fellow Stan
McChrystal thank everybody for being
here and and Hank let me thank you Wendy
particularly for being here what we're
going to talk today is about leadership
there's going to be a financial
component to it and there's probably a
lot more expertise on that then in the
stands then they'll ever be in my seat
up here well because we're talking about
leadership I want to remind you what the
Roman poet said Virgil he said trust one
who has been through it now that's the
only Roman poet quote I have but it's
always it's always good to start with
one Hank we're honored to have you today
here and I and I really appreciate
secretary of the Treasury Henry Hank
Paulson brings four decades of
experience in public policy and economic
background to us and that culminated in
his tenure as US Treasury secretary he
previously to that served as chairman
and chief executive of Goldman Sachs
most importantly he's a graduate of
Dartmouth were among other things he was
all East all Ivy and an honorable
mention all-american offensive lineman
on the football team he is a graduate of
Harvard Business School and is currently
a distinguished senior fellow at the
University of Chicago Harris School of
Public Policy Studies he also has
founded the Paulson Institute an
independent center located at the
University of Chicago dedicated to
fostering international engagement to
address issues of global importance and
as you know he's a deep expert
on China and he's taken more than 80
trips there so there's as we discuss
activities today one of the things that
you know I discussed a little while ago
is relationships and personal
relationships and how they how to make
an impact policy and of course his
insights on China in that regard would
be huge I think what I'd like to do is
start out by just sort of hitting you up
front it says a lot of times we're asked
if leaders are born and made or made and
it's secretary of the Treasury you've
faced one of the most challenging
periods in our history certainly
financially so as a leader were you born
or made well first of all let me say
it's it's it's terrific to be here with
you all today and it's it's an honor to
be here with stand now in terms of
leadership you all may know what you
want to be but when I was I was
graduating from Dartmouth College when I
went to Dartmouth College I thought I
wanted to be a forest ranger I like I
like the outdoors I ended up as an
investment banker but I was always very
suspicious of people who came out of
their mother's womb knowing they wanted
to be an investment banker you know
i-i-i spent a few years in government
before spending years in finance and but
what I really do believe the training
that I had before I got to Treasury
helped prepare me for the challenges I
was going to going to go through at
Treasury but I happen to believe that
that life experience and training is
very important to leadership was there a
single biggest experience in the way up
that you remember no stand there really
wasn't the the I'm probably not a good
example of this because I know many
people say I want to be a CEO or I want
to run this or that I what what I did
was I I I ended up in government right
out of it right out of business
I ended up working in the Pentagon the
for David Packard and an Assistant
Secretary of Defense I found I enjoyed
financial issues so I went to work for
goldman sachs and actually I turned down
promotions I was I didn't go there if
you went to work for an investment bank
you didn't go there wanting to run it
you wanted to work with many companies
and solve problems and so I'm always a
little bit suspicious of career
engineers people that want to map it out
I think that that is a young person you
can afford almost anything other than
not to learn and grow and to learn to
grow do things you enjoy and that's
really what I focused on and then as my
put the career progressed I found I
enjoyed management leadership you've got
a few Pentagon veterans in the room as
well as others would probably aspire and
can you compare the experience in the
Pentagon with that what you got in your
early years at Goldman Sachs well why
don't I do it more for government okay
just generally because government is
managing leading in business is in many
ways very different than any government
that I think the Pentagon a military is
something else we which we can get to
but just overall I think it takes the
same skill sets but it takes a different
mindset because it's much more difficult
in government much much more difficult
because you just take the position as
Treasury secretary as Treasury secretary
the only Authority there you have is
essentially what the president gives you
you say you have a boss and so the key
is your relationship with the President
and then a lot of your success is going
to be your ability to to persuade others
you know whether it's regulators or a
member of members of Congress or others
to do things that you want to get done
so it's it's not leading by Fiat I'm not
saying you don't do that
the best people don't do that in
business either but it is still much
more difficult in government because
it's as I explained to people all the
time you could have the best idea but
unless you can persuade others to adopt
it it's it's basically a worthless idea
so being able to persuade others being
able to find common ground in government
there's very little low-hanging fruit
things are either analytically difficult
like if you want to get health care
reform done it's analytically difficult
or Social Security reform is
analytically simple but politically
difficult so so everything is it's
important in government is difficult to
get done much more difficult to get done
now I think the Pentagon and getting in
the military it's it's it's another set
of issues what kind of issues well again
I was there as a civilian and so I was I
was there was a civilian
I didn't didn't wear a uniform but it
was again and I dealt with that also
with political issues because people are
gonna think that this all I know how to
do is bailouts but my first assignment
was the locky bailout you remember so I
worked in which is very so I I work too
is but and and frankly I didn't support
that one because I didn't think we you
know not that anybody cared what my
position was that was very junior but
the but and there it was again working
with Congress it was it was a political
process but my experience which was
telling you earlier from the military is
I think what I was pleasantly surprised
at you know how expert you know all the
people I worked in at the Pentagon were
in terms of the training I think the
military does the best job of training
people yeah so I that was one of my
enduring impressions and the other was
the amount of waste in
efficiency that we have and which was
just extraordinary and how much some of
the system decisions were made were
political again responding to masters in
Congress and you know and and you know
so on any of that but that's not we came
here to talk about why were there any
people that you saw in government
service when you were younger that you
thought epitomized the most effective
leadership in that environment
well I it's very interesting because the
I get asked all the time stand to take
shots at people in government and
there's a lot I don't like about the
process but for the most part people I
saw worked very very hard whether
they're in Congress or in the executive
branch where no one goes that are trying
to do a bad job you know everybody's
doing their best the political jobs are
particularly difficult those that need
to get elected but the people you know I
very much admired David Packard who was
a founder of Hewlett Packard it was a
Deputy Secretary of Defense and I
thought he was a really outstanding man
but yet he wasn't terribly effective at
dealing with the bureaucracy because he
I don't think ever made the adjustment
as well as he needed to that he wasn't
at a company and he could be overseeing
the f-14 program which was a fighter jet
program and he could say to the Admiral
who was running it you know I want to
know if there's going to be any or to
the captain at the time if there was any
over one I want to know about it and
surprise surprise you know the guy would
make Admiral and then two weeks later it
would come out there was an overrun and
he knew he wasn't working for for David
Packard he was working for the head of
of NAVAIR or something so
so it is I think that there are some
people that that were able that I think
to be very very good at at the substance
and at the politics you know I I i
admired melvin laird frankly who i
thought was it was an excellent treasury
secretary defense and i had the
opportunity to work with to work with
george shultz well he was treasury
secretary and he was he was at the at
the treasury when I was at the White
House how was it different when you
transition to the private sector what
did you carry from government that
worked what didn't work how did you grow
well and in terms of the I thought
government was a great experience
for the private sector just a great
experience because you you learn how to
multitask you learn that you're not
going to be successful unless you can
unless you can communicate either in
writing or verbally you learn a lot
about working with others and I thought
that I had and I didn't realize it at
the time but I had the opportunity to go
from the Pentagon to the White House to
work with the cabinet secretaries and
the president before I was 27 years old
and so then when you it that gives you
it increases your sense of confidence
and and as I said the skill set is very
similar to what it takes in the private
sector it's just a different different
mindset in the private sector you you
continued your evolution as a leader
before 2006 you became Treasury
secretary was there anything in that
private sector period that you thought
particularly suited you besides sort of
financial experience for yeah well for
me it was again I've watched business
leaders go to government and some be
successful and some
be successful and the ones that aren't
successful are the ones that either
either don't understand that they're no
longer the boss or or even if they
understand it intellectually they can't
emotionally get to that place and I
think the fact that in my career I not
only understood finance but I had done
so much work with clients I had advised
heads of state that advised worked with
many many CEOs and so I realized you
know emotionally and intellectually
understood what it was to even when I
was a CEO to work for someone else to
work for the principal to advise them to
persuade them so I came out of an
environment where there was a premium
placed on working with others selling
others there was and I think that helped
me a lot and then I'm I am everyone's
different and I'm decisive by nature and
I think that that particular skill set
was a good one to have when I happen to
be in Washington I'd say the other thing
that I learned I learned from not only
doing things but from watching others
and so I got to work with many many CEOs
around the world and one of the things
that became very obvious to me and
watching them was that there is no
leader anywhere no head of state no CEO
you pick the best ones they all have
weaknesses everyone they're all people
they all have weaknesses and the
weaknesses are usually the flipside of a
positive hank is candid Hank is
indiscreet Hank is decisive Hank is a
thoughtful enough or whatever and so as
you move up and taking on more and more
senior positions the world is very
unforgiving
and it always will find out and uncover
the weaknesses so the good ones are
self-aware and they surround themselves
with people that have complementary
skill sets people that can cover up for
their weaknesses and and so that I think
helped me more than anything when I
became a CEO of Goldman Sachs and in
terms of it and helped me work in
Washington and so that's that I think
that was one of the things I learned and
then I went through I went through a
number of crises financial crises when I
was at Goldman Sachs what was the
biggest challenge of Goldman Sachs what
was the one that you you think has the
moment well I would the I would say the
the biggest one was what was in 1998
when we had postponed our public
offering because we had losses there was
a the financial crisis you remember rush
of default that there was Asian
financial crisis it had it was a
liquidity crisis and so that was and I'd
say it would throw in a 94 just when I
came up to become the chief operating
officer and and of the firm and I'll say
this about crises when people when
people say to me well you know what is
it like going through something that was
as impactful as you know the financial
crisis in 2007 and eight you know when
you're going through a crisis even one
that's a lot smaller than that
it feels pretty much the same I mean it
crisis is the crisis that you're not
saying well you know if I'm boiling in
oil it doesn't make much difference if
it's right 180 degrees or 200 degrees
it's you're still boiling in oil so so I
boiled in oil before some of these guys
can tell you every firefight feels like
Gettysburg and upon where you are yeah
let's move to that your assumption of
the job as Treasury secretary when you
walked into the job how did you think
the landscape of governor it was the
last quarter of
administration last two years well how
did you sense that the environment was
well Stan I had not said I was III I
joined two and a half years in the
middle of 2006 with two and a half years
to go and I I had turned the job down
twice which tells you what I mean I had
I had a mother who who you know was just
terribly distressed
I mean cried you know when I accepted
she said you started off working for
Richard Nixon and now George Bush he
should be ashamed of yourself you know I
had I had I had I had a wife you know in
a matter of fact I had I had benefactors
I was walking out of a lunch for who
Ching tau at the White House and the
spring of 2006 Wendy could see I was
rather quiet and she said I hope you
didn't turn down this job because of me
and I said oh oh no I did for other
reasons and and she said well that's
good sweetie because it was very
important you I would have agreed and I
took that when I they came back the
third time that accepted but but but but
I what what my concern was it really
gets to your your earlier question I was
worried about what I could do working
with a president who was you know 28%
approval ratings at that time the last
two and a half years but I think truth
be told when they came back the third
time I really was asking myself will I
be successful you know I knew I could be
successful in the private sector I knew
enough about government - you know
wonder whether I could be successful and
and so I think that was a and then as
soon as I recognized that that was
holding me back I said boy I don't want
to give him
that fear and you know fear of failure
and so and I really owe a great deal of
my country so I accept it but then when
I when I came on it was it it I had
underestimated the opportunity because
even without the financial crisis what I
found was everyday if you define your
job expansively which is what I think
good leaders that need to do there were
things you know we started up the
strategic economic dialogue with China
we did we do all kinds of things that
you can do in government so I you know
my mindset when I went on was to was to
run a hundred miles an hour it's great
approach is we came upon the crisis that
that turned into the financial crisis
how soon did you recognize it as a storm
cloud coming and how accurately do you
feel you got it now in hindsight well
it's interesting because I
underestimated the extent of the problem
every step of the way right up until we
got the tarp authority but yet when I
showed up in Washington I was expecting
a problem the President had asked me in
the very first meeting at Camp David
with the economic team to talk about
entitlements reform which is one of the
reasons why I had come and I said no I
don't want to talk about that I'd like
to talk about the financial crisis I
think we're overdue for one and I see a
lot of excesses and so we talked about
that and I focused on over-the-counter
derivatives and he said to me if the
crisis comes what will cause it and I
said I don't know sir but I tell you one
thing when it when it does happen it'll
be obvious after the fact you know I
didn't see Russia I didn't see Asia and
so right away I started getting the
president's
answer group the other regulators
working with closely with Ben Bernanke
and Tim and others Tim Geithner it was
at the New York Fed right away we
started working I started the
relationships of working with members of
Congress on reform of Fannie and Freddie
and so I I was I think I was more
concerned than most people there almost
anyone but what I'd missed was that what
I think most people missed was because a
bubble by definition you don't know the
extent of it until it burst was that we
weren't just dealing with subprime we'd
housing prices had been no time since
World War two that you'd had a general
decline in residential housing prices
because we had all these flawed policies
to overstimulate houses causing prices
and so the risk you had if you got a
residential mortgage was you'd get paid
back too quickly and so I had missed
that and and and it really the extent of
the overall credit model because that
was it was and so but I would say this
if I'd been a mission I couldn't have
done a different thing in other words we
I was working we got incredible
authorities and we in and it took Fannie
and Freddie you know getting ready to go
down to get the first set and and the
House voted no to the tarp even the
first time but but so I was on to this
early on but the extent of it no sort of
philosophically you described yourself
as decisive and in your book it's pretty
clear and the other accounts it's pretty
clear as well there's always a tendency
for leaders to also be cautious some
people say don't rush to make a mistake
what's the balance there particularly
when a situation is unclear well you
need to the week that we could talk for
a long time which I'm trying to use
you're probably wearing brevity isn't my
greatest asset so I'll try to be brief
err here but when you're
energy in a crisis you know you're going
to be working with imperfect information
right and if you wait till you get all
the information you like you'll be
looking in the rearview mirror it'll be
too late and when you're dealing with a
big messy unprecedented problem there's
going to be no elegant perfect solution
you know it's going to be and so the
crisis the timing is you always have to
trade off acting without sufficient
information and without a perfect
solution against the cost of inaction
and there was never a situation where I
really was debating gee how much longer
should I wait I mean this this was what
you have to be prepared to act and then
if the facts change are your
understanding changes you've got to be
persuade you've got to be prepared to
change and so the so I did a number of
things that I think we're very
objectionable but they are easy to do
because they were better than the
alternative and so that was that's the
way I thought about it as you start to
act there are always a group of people
being pundants media or even people
around you that are sort of whispered in
your ear saying you're going the wrong
way you're doing the wrong thing hold
off go faster how do you personally deal
with that the most interesting stand
because I think my situation was
probably different than yours where
everybody was debating different
strategy and so to just describe mine
there was this unprecedented situation
and and I wasn't surrounded by people
who said I've got a better idea
okay and so what I found was this that
if and I a great partner I mean Ben
Bernanke and Tim Geithner we you know I
had a
huge advantage I had a year before the
crisis to build a relationship with
George Bush of trust and he was just a
terrific boss just terrific in terms of
he was a quick study understood and he
only cared about what was the right
thing for the economy he didn't worry
about the political reaction or or you
know ideologies or whatever and so I
because I had a boss who kept bucking me
up and kept saying you know we're not
going to worry about politics we're
gonna save this economy and and because
I had those really good partners what
what I was dealing with was this first
of all if you had an idea and no one had
a better idea the idea even it was an
imperfect idea one and other people if
they didn't have a better idea or if
they were scared they didn't you know
they didn't they didn't fight you so the
the issue that I dealt with was the
politics people that worked with me took
courage because when you did things that
you knew going in was going to be very
unpopular it's first of all if you're a
politician and you've got to run for
office that's really hard I mean the
first time I went up to the hill and and
talked to Congress and said we we needed
the tarp authorities and Ben and I
explained that the financial arteries
were frozen and what was going to happen
to the economy in a number of months but
it was could be an absolute collapse if
we didn't get this Authority barney
frank said to me Hank this is bad you
can't you'll never prove a contractual
and this was late at night and I said
Barney what's the counter of actually
you know well he said listen if if you
go you'll never get credit for
preventing a catastrophe people didn't
see you're gonna say we're in deep
doo-doo give us this Authority and we'll
and you'll get it and if it all works
people will say it didn't work see we're
you know
we still have a problem so every member
of Congress that voted for the tarp
unless they were stupid and there
weren't many of them that were stupid
knew that that was an unpopular vote and
so the kinds of resistance you got in
Congress was no one worked against me in
Congress some people stepped aside and
stood up and made speeches heads of
certain committees and made speeches but
if they worked against it we wouldn't
have got the authority you know and
others some some voted no because you
know I guess because they sincerely
didn't understand the problem but I
think most of the people that voted now
they just knew it was going to be a very
unpopular vote and and in the
administration I I had the support of
the president in the executive branch
and I had a team one of the conditions I
had on coming down to Washington was
that I would be able to replace all
political appointees regardless of party
we wouldn't and I had I saw I had a
really good team and people in the
executive branch that cared about what a
lot about what the public thought about
him or were concerned that they'd be
investigated or criticized just sort of
stepped aside or were ineffective but it
wasn't like people said well we should
pursue a different strategy or or we
shouldn't do nation building or whatever
right I mean when you talk about saving
a financial system it's not like there
were a lot of with insufficient
authorities it weren't like there was it
wasn't like there was a lot of people
standing there saying I got another idea
and and you know and some people said
well we just you know some Congress
people in Congress said well if we just
change the accounting and don't have
mark to market accounting the problem
will go away well that was that was just
a talking point they I don't think they
really really believed that in there are
two hearts you talked about
relationships a little while ago and yet
you had long-standing relationships with
a lot of the players in this and some
shorter term can you talk about where
they were important how you nurture them
how you maintain them in the crisis well
first of all again and I would say this
to everyone in this room and I just
can't emphasize it enough that the
leadership is or being effective is is
finding common ground working with other
people listening with other people so I
had a year to do this and before the
crisis and so I had a real opportunity
to you know I added I had a deal with
George Bush when I joined I would be the
primary spokesman an advisor on all
domestic and international economic
issues but I knew that if it didn't work
that paper wasn't worth anything and
that and it would be my fault them out
here so I I had to develop that
relationship of trust and then I had it
I had a team at Treasury where I I
selected them and these were people that
I knew had skills that complemented mine
and knew how to get things done and I
then had the the other understanding I
had with the president which he really
welcomed was that I wouldn't be partisan
I wouldn't get involved in any politics
I wouldn't get involved in the election
so I knew to get things done the
leadership of the hill were Democrats
and so I started working with Barney
Frank very early on reform of Fannie and
Freddie and the Republicans had one view
and I actually agreed with the
Republicans but I didn't want to leave
him about getting anything done without
compromising so I in in Barney to me was
a real hero I mean he when we got the
authorities we got it was a working
relationship with him I had an
opportunity to work with Nancy Pelosi on
a trade deal and stimulus I worked it
had good
we had Harry Reid over for a chicken
dinner and we got to know him and I
worked with him on a lot of things and
so so
that is and just meeting someone doesn't
do it we've had opportunities to work
together I worked on with so that was
critical because there's got to be a
certain level of trust or you just not
going to get things done can you jump
that into your longtime relationship
with some of the Chinese leaders well I
don't think Chinese frankly I think this
is pretty universal you know i-i-i we
were just talking coming in
stan was asking me about how important
relations
our ships are in China and they are
important but they're important
everywhere and it helps again if you've
worked with people now in China I had
the great privilege of working with a
number of the people that are important
leaders now and former leaders the most
important early transactions the first
privatizations China Mobile Bank of
China Petra China I had an opportunity
to work on was young German on parks in
Yunnan I'm very interested in
conservation and and I had I've always
been interested in spending time on
different on I always tell people that
that work-life balance is important I've
been interested in conservation and so I
chaired a group a conservation group in
Asia I worked with xuanji and putting
together and he was a former premier of
China setting up an executive management
program at Jinghua and that's how I got
to know who chain tile it was a current
president
so again life is is in and getting to
know them and a relationship isn't gee
shaking hands and and having having
dinner and exchanging cards and so on
it's it's it's working to get things
done we've got a roomful of high
achievers who've been very successful
and you had a life from Dartmouth on
tremendous string of successes what was
your biggest mistake or failure and any
regrets and how do you deal with that
well let's say this it's an interesting
thing that I can't point to to any
single big regret or failure but I can
tell you one thing which is fascinating
I I have always had a philosophy that
the which is to find the job expansively
and run to problems rather than run away
and so I've tended to be aggressive and
I had once you know I don't know 20
years ago at Goldman Sachs
I had one of my fellow partners say to
me you know for a joke you know Hank is
going to make a speech to everybody not
on the limits of aggressiveness and it's
going to be one word none you know and
and and so I I stood up and I remember
just simply saying there really are
limits because the you know and talked a
lot about integrity and actually always
knowing you're doing the right thing and
never being afraid if you don't if
someone asked you to do something
because I was at the White House during
Watergate and it just was I learned an
incredible lesson when I watched you
know it's never really interesting why
there not a lot of bad people why bad
people do bad things that's not
interesting at all right it's not
interesting why good people do good
things but why good people do bad things
is very interesting and so I I talked
about groupthink and people making a
mistake because their boss tells them to
do something and they're they're afraid
to ask a question but then once you put
that aside which is very important I
said as aggressive as I am I the
mistakes I've made all of them were
errors of omission not Commission in
other words were trained to
not push the envelope or to ask
embarrassing questions or to try to
persuade people to do something they
don't want to do even if you think it's
right and so I think that's that's right
and then I tend not to look back you
know I the you know I get asked a lot
during the financial crisis
what mistakes that's all but want me to
talk about that a little better here
please so that would be because it's an
interesting thing I and I made plenty of
mistakes I don't and I will talk about a
number up in a minute but I think the
biggest things as I look back now I just
say how fortunate I was because I think
with really inadequate authorities and a
really flawed regulatory system we dealt
with an unprecedented situation and I
think the big decisions we made we got
right and they prevented a far worse
crisis but I think a lot of the things
that we as I look back a lot of things
we get criticized for were were not
mistakes like for instance Lehman
Brothers going down you know a lot of
people even though Ben Bernanke and Tim
Geithner and I have all said we couldn't
find an authority to save them we wanted
to say but a lot of people questioned
that no one said here's the authority
and it would have saved them I mean we
just we couldn't put capital we couldn't
guarantee a Fed loan into a into a into
a bank run doesn't work so and and some
of the mistakes I made or misjudgments
fortuitous in other words we're very
lucky
I could never twice I had to go to
Congress and get really unprecedented
Authority with Fannie or Freddie I said
I need unlimited my staff said you can't
get unlimited so we asked for
unspecified I got unspecified but
but-but-but if I go on and said we're
gonna nationalize Fannie or Freddie we
wouldn't have got it and I didn't
believe we needed to I thought if I had
the bazooka I wouldn't have to use it I
didn't know they had the problem was
until we got inside with tarp I actually
hoped and believed we could use illiquid
assets purchases and if I gone to
Congress and said we want to put capital
in Republicans never would have voted
for it
and fortunately I sincerely believed
everything I said I thought we were
going to put in illiquid assets in we
got some capital Authority if we
internationalized banks that they failed
and when it was clear the problem was so
severe we switched so I was fortuitous
my the mistakes were all ones of
communication it was just a whole series
of things I sent up at midnight a three
page outline to Congress on target that
they that got perceived as laying
arrogant take her to leave it that was
supposed to be a starting point for a
discussion that it wasn't definitively
what we needed or whatever but you know
I had a lot of other press conferences
at midnight I might as well at a press
conference here and explain that but but
we didn't do it I never did a good job
of explaining setting expectations on
bank lending and saying you know there's
no way the government can or should make
banks lend make lend more than what or
how its government going to make them
lend or letting people know it was going
to take a while and you know I never
ever there's this last one I used to say
it was a mistake and now I I really
wonder whether it was possible I never
ever explained in a convincing way to
the American people that that the bank
rescues were for the American people not
for the banks and and when I left office
92% of the Americans were against the
tarp in the same poll 60% were against
torture right and so so the the
that is stop think about that for a
minute and but but on the one hand on
the other I don't think it's all wrong
that the American people don't like
bailouts and and if we had all the tools
we needed we wouldn't have made a damn
bailouts but so so but most leaders I
know and most ones I admire if he had
major setbacks and then picked
themselves up from that step back and I
wish I could tell that story but I just
never had any in my career
yeah but gave yourself yeah the yeah I'd
like to open it just for any less
thoughts you but I'd like to open it for
questions in the in the audience
anything you've got
I've got no less thought so I think we
there's many questions as we have the
better great sure name is Jason tubes
I'm a sophomore in America we often
admire leaders who can make a decision
and see it through to the very end when
do you think it's appropriate to stick
to a decision and what do you think it's
appropriate to renegotiate or compromise
on a position you've taken I think
that's a really key question and I would
say that I think when you know if you
know conclusively something as a mistake
or the facts change a good leader
changes and I have all my life I've
prided myself on having a point of view
but listening and you know not not
changing just because it's being
criticized or because it's it's
unpopular or you hear and you know some
leaders you know I but you know I just
known leaders that they get briefed one
day they make a decision someone else
comes in and gives them a briefing the
next day and or
persuasive and they they and they go you
know that they change and obviously you
can't do that but I will tell you I made
I made a a couple of reversals and I I
didn't debate about it a second
I remember going and seeing George Bush
and telling him you know we'd gone in we
we just give you a story we we went to
Congress I I didn't want a nationalized
banks the idea was to recapitalize banks
are buying illiquid assets the situation
worsened to the point that that that we
had banks going down all across Europe
that our financial system was teetering
we need to move quickly the 700 billion
dollars in tarp I mean we needed to
ultimately do something to do with three
hundred and fifty billion of bad assets
at Citi I mean it it wouldn't have gone
very far so when I went to the President
and told him that we're gonna change and
we designed a very very unique program
nothing had ever been done like this
before it I think in the world which
wasn't nationalizing banks but just
putting capital in a lot of banks he
basically said wow you know that this is
you know it could surprise a lot of
people all around the world and and but
he quickly also said to me you know
you've got to do what you got to do and
do what it takes to to save our economy
so I didn't that was an easy decision
for me is politically uncomfortable as
it was because I thought we either were
looking at that or the collapse of the
system you know that was that was not
like a hard decision to make but but I
actually think you show me a leader that
doesn't change their mind and I think
you're looking at a poor leader because
we've talked about crises today
but I would go further even if it's not
a crisis if you're a in a business
situation or in a military situation or
whatever I would argue that if you
you'll never have all the information
you want or it's too late
and if information changes the world
changes facts change you better be
prepared to change now there's certain
things you know maybe certain principles
that are just in violet but those better
be few and far between like your
integrity anybody yeah sir um so earlier
in the talk you mentioned that you you
know really learned by watching other
leaders I was wondering when you are
looking at leaders when you were looking
at leaders what are the key things that
you try to see you know is that their
decisions is their relationships like
what do you look for when you're
studying other leaders interesting thing
as I said everybody's got strengths and
weaknesses and but I say there's certain
things that most good leaders have in
common and in no particular order I
think they are intellectually curious
they they just have an insatiable
appetite to keep learning and so I think
that's true about most good leaders I
think that most good leaders care about
people and if they don't you know
they're not authentic they get found out
it's amazing the mistakes you can make
along the way and have your team try to
have your team want to help you if you
care about them so I used to have people
that you know that worked for me that
would want to be mentored and I'd better
them I'd say but wait a minute you're
not taking care of those that work for
you and you could see that I could see
the leaders that really cared about the
organization
caring about the people I think that was
important I think most good leaders do
what I call it define the job
expansively
I point that out because I can see young
people from the day I started working
with them right up until people became
CEOs if you define your job expensively
you're not looking at any task narrowly
you're saying how does it fit into the
bigger picture how is it relevant and
you're helping create their jobs I would
say people that work for me I would tell
them that they promote themselves before
I promote them so different finding that
I tell you the really good leaders don't
sit there like they're at a spectator at
a ballgame and say how could those
idiots do this I mean the the good
leaders are accountable and they run to
run to problems and rather than pointing
the fingers elsewhere the really good
leaders don't personalize you just don't
do it it's it's not about you it's about
the organization it's about the mission
you don't make ad hominem attacks if
people criticize your decisions you
don't take it personally and I really
respected and and they listened so and
they've got people skills but other than
that and they've got a great sense of
integrity the very best leaders they're
not working for money they're they've
got a higher purpose but you you take
that aside they come all shapes sizes
you know they they you know some are
some are better salespeople some are
better analytically but but the good
ones as I said earlier were self-aware
so I came away if I had to have if I had
one thing I knew when I became head of a
firm was I better be self-aware and I
better put people around me
you know real diversity you know and and
the other thing is well anyways I'll
leave it at that advic I have a question
concerning a political leadership as
opposed to your leadership in business
and that is the relationship between
strategy and tactics strategy and
tactics yes yeah absent the crisis of
course for which I cannot have ex-ante a
strategy but when you came into your
into your job did you have a strategic
vision as to where you want want it to
go the other leaders that you saw did
you feel that they had a vision as a
strategy long-term strategy whether
wants to go or did you see them as
people who just want to stick around as
long as possible and make tactical
adjustments in order to to arrive
somewhere how did you reconcile these
two elements we it will get me going on
this right now because I believe we are
the strongest richest nation
economically in the world and we've got
fewer problems than any other nation but
that we have a failed political process
that's greatly flawed and I think what
you tend to see is people do you know
for political leaders the the public is
you know the votes are their jobs and
they care about being reelected they
care about public opinion so it's very
difficult to get things done and to have
a long term view if you're running for
office every two years and if you care
about being elected and so just take
taxes well I'll take two things I'll
take taxes and I'll take income
inequality but let me let me take taxes
okay
we have a failed tax system we shouldn't
be debating what the rates should be on
those that make more than two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars you know
progressivity and having the rich pay
more isn't
is an easy thing to do what we should be
it we need more tax revenues you know
tax revenues are like 15 to 16% of GDP
today they've averaged over 18 percent
for the last 40 years and they probably
need to be more than that today so the
only question is what form of taxes will
give us the revenues we need and let us
be competitive create jobs and growth
and no one no one no one will say that
the current system is the right one and
if you put political leaders in in a
room and members of Congress both sides
of the aisle give them truth serum
they're meeting individually they all
know this and they all know that we need
an answer so we need bipartisan
compromise the deficit you know I was
saying to stand earlier the biggest
threat to our national security is debt
okay and we don't have a debt crisis we
have a government crisis you know people
could solve that you know both Simpson
gave us the the answer to that I mean
you could solve that if we spread the
sacrifice around and so my own view is
we have structural issues that predated
the Great Recession or the financial
crisis and that effect they helped
caused it you know income have been
stagnant for decades in this country in
the middle class incomes and that's part
of what caused people to borrow so much
and while we had a household debt that
way above any kind of sustainable level
so the the question for me and I don't
want to be a pessimist because twice I
got Congress to act and do things that
were very unpopular took a crisis but we
didn't it didn't have to collapse first
but I we're gonna have to solve some of
these problems they're all solvable but
the public can't send people to office
and say give us benefits we don't want
to pay for which is what most Western
democracies are doing today
and so it takes but I believe
if if we had you know I had a a guy I
you know I sat next to the other day if
he was happen to be a very conservative
Republican senator and I probably won't
quote him by name but he what he said
was you know we'd solve all the problems
if we had one Congress all the senators
and all the members of the house saying
I'm here only for one term I'm not going
to run again I'm going to do this for my
nation this is going to be the gift to
the United States of America I'm here
for one term now let's get together and
sellable our problems but yeah so the
key thing is no we don't take a
long-term strategic view to taxes to
healthcare to social security to
immigration to education whatever go
ahead
so we focus a lot on how to be a leader
but not enough on why from all the
leaders that you've come across mr.
Paulson what have you seen other than a
higher mission has been a factor driving
personally these leaders and what do you
do well I believe I try to think how I
can say this I I I think to say I want
to lead is the wrong way to look at life
they think what all of us want to do is
to make a difference to be relevant and
so and I think happiness and
satisfaction comes from working hard to
achieve something that's not easy this
is difficult to achieve and makes a
difference and so when people would come
to me that Goldman Sachs and say you
know Hank I don't know should I go to
Asia should I go to Europe should I be a
trader should I be an investment banker
I'd say you're asking me I mean what is
it you really are interested in care
about and so I think with most people
today it starts with what do you what do
you care about where is what is your
people use the word overuse the word
passion don't but what do you really
what really interests you and they don't
think I tell people all the time there
is no perfect job there is no such thing
there's nothing perfect in the world but
there's a right one for you and the
important thing is it's to do something
where you're going to learn and grow and
get skills which will then let you make
a difference in things you want to do
and there's different forms of
leadership people trust me I know all
kinds of I've worked with all sorts of
people people have made it to the very
top and I know all sorts of I don't know
a single CEO or people the person that
made it to the top of any organization
that says well you know I made it to the
top but I screwed up my family life I
don't have any
but I'm happy you know yeah and I know
and I know many people that didn't get
exactly where they wanted to get
professionally but they've got a good
work/life balance
they're doing things they're interested
in and and they're doing things they do
well the other thing it's which I think
young people make I just watched young
people make the mistake of saying this
sounds good I'm gonna do it because
they're even it's a hard job again
everybody wants to get it or as opposed
to saying I want to pick something I'm
going to enjoy and do well so I think
leaders I can tell qualities I can look
at young people and say they've got
qualities they're gonna let them be
outstanding leaders but that may mean
that they're being a great teacher or a
principal or that they're going to be
great in science or the military or
whatever it they're what I call
difference makers people that have got
ideas and people that it can can't
persuade others but there are different
leadership styles and some if some
people don't want it and it's not right
for them making the important leaders
and not be the top person in an
organization I don't know does that help
it thank you
you mentioned earlier that your sort of
biggest regret was not being able to
properly communicate to the American
people that the bailouts were for them
and not for the banks and I think from
my perspective it seems like a lot of
the anger is because Wall Street were
covered long before Main Street yeah I
was wondering if you could comment on
whether you thought leaders on Wall
Street acted irresponsibly and giving
themselves bonuses sort of which they
couldn't have done without taxpayer
money yeah I would say that the I think
that's right first of all the answer it
is yes there was anger to the at the
bonuses and compensation levels on Wall
Street no doubt about it
I also believe that there was the way
the the way the situation worked first
of all to just step back a bit people on
Wall Street made all kinds of mistakes
huge mistakes but in every financial
crisis what has generally happened to go
back from the history of time the crises
take place the root cause isn't the
banks
it never is it's flawed government
policies one of the policies that caused
us to overstimulate housing Fannie or
Freddie interest rate deduction on any
mortgage a million dollars or whatever
FHA program state programs one of the
policies that caused us to tax policies
that borrow and too much and not save
its etc we I could go through any but
what happens is there's then people
always blame the banks and that's fine
blaming the banks because there's things
that they got to change but if you don't
fix the ultimate problem the your you're
gonna be back there again then secondly
what happens is the way it it always
happens in terms of the economy the
problem will show up first at the banks
and the reason you need to do something
for the banks is if they collapse boy
it's it's then you're going to the
economic dark ages you know
there was a time when there was we had
three point eight trillion dollars in
money market floods and they were
getting ready to implode and you know
that they were funding commercial paper
that corporations were used to borrowing
and we came so close to having we had
triple-a industrial companies that
couldn't sell commercial paper so if we
had a situation where if gone down not
only would be there thirty million
Americans that had their money and money
market funds they thought they were
money good but all the companies
wouldn't be able to make their payments
on accounts payable or lay off that
workers it would just be a vicious cycle
so you so but the problem starts at the
banks and then if it works the way it
should the bank should recover first
so the banks recovered first but there
was insensitivity because but but I
think even even without the bonuses the
thing that I had totally underestimated
and most members of the press told me
they underestimated most members of
Congress said they underestimated was
when we put the money in the banks we
weren't nationalizing them we put him
not just in failing banks we asked the
banks to take it because rather than
dealing with serial one-off failures and
nationalizing them we wanted to
recapitalize so we put in preferred some
very attractive terms knowing that the
money would come back and I actually
thought we put that money in and that
we'd have three thousand banks take it
they'd hold it for three to five years
would be better than a stimulus plan etc
but the press immediately started
writing about nationalization and the
public hated it
the FDIC guarantee which was a bigger
benefit the public didn't understand but
and so then it got stigmatized and in
the program worked because the money
came back with a profit and the banks
paid it back pretty quickly and many of
them did it we'll only 700 took it but
my point is the American people even if
there
the bonus was a huge hot point but the
banks not lending you know even though
people had more than what you know more
than they would have lent should have
let if they if they collapse more than
they should have that they went to the
height of the bubble but I would say
that no matter what it happened the
American people would have blamed the
banks and the program would have been
stigmatized and that's not all bad
because we shouldn't in the United
States of America you know if you take a
risk and you make a profit people
understand it if you take a risk and the
taxpayer pays for it they don't
understand it and what we really needed
was authorities so that we could wind
down failing institutions and they
wouldn't be propped up in their in their
current form but that's I think we've
probably got time for one or two more
questions max so let's go clear sir
I'm from Beijing China so and as the
vacantly I'm from your law school so I
ask questions regarding China because
it's the global first Institute event so
two weeks ago like our the West primates
plant mr. XI team he invaded the
Washington DC in the first day first
night mr. xie have dinner with lot of
old friends as you you are joined
together so I'm just wondering could you
kind to invite it is the historic trip
about mr. XI and is any difference to
current president who and other you know
refer the generation telus leaders cuz
is true a sheep most likely to be the I
was leader in the next three years and
also like I wonder currently like three
term McKeon and Republic candidate from
president candidate Romani have Lada
like criticized China I am The Wall
Street Journal so I just wanna like with
your comment about American leadership
in Asia and the China the risk the rise
in the tomorrow and the us-china
relationship thank you so much I'll try
to be brief here you're right I did have
dinner with shame thing when he arrived
I've known him for a while actually my
first trip to China's Treasury secretary
I stopped in Hangzhou and saw him before
I went on to Beijing and so the other
leaders in 2006 I think he is he's going
to be a strong leader he is is a quite
self-confident he you know he was in the
dinner very unscripted spontaneous and
he's going to need to be a strong leader
because when you look at the volatility
in the world and you look at the
challenges he will face over the next 10
years because the expectations of the
Chinese public continues to rise as you
know they've got great expectations and
given the size and couple
city of that economy and and the massive
change that needs to be managed on a
scale that's never been managed before
it's it's it easy as his work cut out
for him and I think it's really to to
China's benefit and our benefit that
you've got that kind of leadership
because you know the problems that we
have in this country are of our own
making and they're all going to be more
difficult to solve if China has a
problem than if China doesn't so we've
got our differences but but but I think
that almost every problem in the world
becomes easier to solve if there are two
countries it can work together now in
terms of the u.s. leaders being critical
this is a political season right and in
China there's that there's there it's a
political season too you know there's
going to be a government change and
nationalism and protection is in place a
little bit in both countries there's no
doubt that you and you can't go wrong as
a politician in the u.s. criticizing
China in blaming China when you're
running for election but the thing that
I take some comfort in is the leaders of
both parties and what they've done is
they've criticized China and said gee we
want China to play by the rules you know
they're criticizing trade practices in
there we've got you know dispute
resolution authorities you don't need a
trade war you know we've got the WTO you
go to the WTO so I think it is it's it's
a little bit different this time than
other elections because right now we've
got economic challenges and anxiety in
this country and there's there's plenty
of as well as China's doing there's
plenty of challenges in China and
particularly given the uncertainty here
what in what I'd like to see is a vision
from leadership that is whether it's
it's self confidence based upon
acknowledging some of the challenges
we've got and recognizing the best
we're gonna solve them is to be open to
the rest of the world
and I don't think leaders here have
cross the line but I don't think you
should also be overly concerned because
this is a political season and it's a
little bit what I saw you know when when
I wrote my book and the crisis it was a
collision of markets and politics right
what made the crisis so difficult for me
to deal with it was as six weeks before
an election so I was talking to Barack
Obama and John McCain in every couple of
days talking with leader because if any
of the leaders have come out against the
tarp we wouldn't have got you know what
we needed in here I think this is just a
trickier time to manage this
relationship but I think what all of us
who want there to be a strong
relationship between the US and China we
can be very grateful that she's young
being had a terrific trip here I think
the American people got to see him you
know in Iowa and Los Angeles and and I
think I think it I think it was a
positive rather than a divisive trip and
I think that's a good sign it's a
testament to him and it's a testament to
the leaders we have in the United States
then as outside of the election they
still I think treated him with with
great courtesy and and respect showing
the importance of the relations between
our two countries let's go one more in
the back all the way
secretary Paulson thanks first of all
for coming we really appreciate it and
thanks to everyone from Jackson for
organizing this event I think we all
really enjoyed it
secretary Paulson one of the first
things you mentioned was the importance
of being an effective leader of getting
real world experience do you feel that
as you move up to very high levels of
leadership that is maybe a danger that
you might lose some of that real world
perspective that you had but you might
otherwise have
and you think it's a valid concern and
if so what do you do to prevent that and
prevent it becoming out of touch well
that's something I worked on all the
time when I ran Goldman Sachs I think I
had a different approach than just about
any leader and you could be criticized
for it but I spent a reasonable amount
of my time probably a third of my time
working with clients and that wasn't
just calling them and and being the
state's been like roll it was taking
active roles advising clients I thought
that that kept me close to the markets
kept me close to what you know the
losing business when it winning business
let me know what the competition was
doing and and I enjoyed it and when I
was at Treasury it was very interesting
I was terribly fortunate to have a
partner like Ben Bernanke who was a
world it's a tremendous economist in a
study in economic history and and you
know and so knew what had happened with
the Great Depression inside and out and
then what I did was rather than just
looking at Bloomberg machines in quotes
you know it's so on I did something I
got criticized for afterwards but I got
to tell you I'd do it again every day of
the week in the middle of the crisis I
all the time talked with people I didn't
care if they were you know I talked with
with with all sorts of investors I
talked with you know bankers all over
the world you know even when we you know
when we were doing working on you know
stopping terrorism of funding
rather than just working with
governments and talking with the French
or the German government of the Swiss
government I encouraged our people and I
went directly and talked with the you
know CEOs of foreign banks about that
topic so I always I returned every call
I was accessible to people you know
everybody's got their III plenty of
weaknesses but that I needed to do that
okay I I needed to assimilate
information work on deals otherwise you
lose touch very quickly and I got to
tell you today I've been out I could no
more go back and run a financial it's
it's been over five years since I've run
a financial institution I could no more
do it today it'd just be like an athlete
who hasn't worked out for five years you
just have to you have to work hard at
one more
okay my fine they go you thank you very
much you've spoken a few times about the
necessity of persuading others being
being adept at the art of persuasion I
wondered if you could share some of your
own you know what that takes and and and
some of your own approach to that well
everybody's got their own approach and
if any of you have heard me make a
speech you know it's a painful
experience so I certainly didn't
persuade people standing up giving a
public speech and reading it and so to
me what I found
persuasion is is first of all and I
learned this working with clients it
doesn't make any difference you have to
understand what they're thinking you
have to understand what their
perspective is you have to put yourself
if you're advising a CEO in the CEOs
shoes so if I went in you know what one
of the other things I care about was you
know less I care about environmental
issues well if I'm going in to see a
senator from West Virginia
I sort of know where he's where he
starts with on coal mining or if I'm
horrified going to Michigan it seems
someone from Michigan I know where the
Michigan delegation cares about about
that you know some of the regulatory
measures of fuel efficiency and
automobiles or whatever and so you have
to I think you you need to start by
understanding the other person's
perspective in persuading and I think
it's futile to try to explain persuade
people to do things that are in they're
not in their self-interest unless
there's really a strong reason for doing
it or you you have to know how to appeal
to them in and but it's not futile to
try to persuade them if it's not in
their self-interest because I've done
that but you you can't you have to
acknowledge
you have to begin by acknowledging what
the issue is that they're dealing with I
think if you're dealing with with a
foreign country which is a sovereign
nation you you need to you can't always
say well this is what I want I want ABCD
and evil well what are you prepared to
give so part of persuasion is finding a
common ground shared interest and then
it is listening if you don't listen and
understand what their arguments are at
their point of view and if you're just
so busy trying to make your points
you're not going to persuade them I also
think it is based upon a lot of it is
trust I had I had a you know in the tarp
vote we had the Senate Republicans voted
I think 35 to 14 for us we had the
Senate Democrats we had the House
Democrats because here in their
leadership the House Republicans were
more more difficult but I had a I had a
senator tell me that when I met with the
caucus the most effective thing wasn't
all the other arguments I made I just
look at the end when I said listen I
didn't originally want this job I came
here to serve my country
I can never you know I can make all the
arguments in the world and probably a
lot of you will never understand what's
going to happen to the financial system
you just got to trust me
and give give us these authorities or
where this is going to be a very sad day
for our country and he believed it based
upon the way I said it and the fact that
I had a history of working with them so
a lot of it is not just being able to
stand up and make a speech it helps if
you're articulate it helps if you can
write but there's a great advantage to
being able to figure out how to look at
the other man
woman walk-in the other woman's
moccasins understand what she's thinking
understand what he's thinking and then
then try to persuade him too many people
know just what they want or I used to
tell investment bankers you know you're
there to serve the client you're not
there to sell a product you've got to
listen you've got to understand their
situation and say how can I help them
and I think that's what a lot of sales
is and then if you want to persuade
people to do something that it were
there's going to be sacrifice up front
where it's going to be politically
unpopular don't treat them like idiots
explain it it is an appeal to their
higher
to their higher sense absolutely let me
start by thanking president Levin for
creating an environment that that lets
this kind of thing happen you know you
got to know how specialist is let me ask
thank Jim Levinson Ford in the Jackson
Institute for crafting this and helping
us pull this together and first and
foremost secretary let me thank you for
an extraordinary set of insights for
people who are soaking them in my thanks
Stan thank you